[Music]
reaching heights of over 100 meters
Californian sequoias tower over Earth's
other estimated 60,000 tree species
growing in the misty Sierra Nevada
mountains their massive trunks support
the tallest known trees in the world but
even these behemoths seem to have their
limits
no Sequoia on record has been able to
grow taller than 130 meters and many
researchers say these trees won't beat
that cap even if they live for thousands
of years to come so what exactly is
stopping these trees from growing taller
forever it all comes down to SAP in
order for trees to grow they need to
bring sugars obtained from
photosynthesis and nutrients brought in
through the root system to wherever
growth is happening and just like blood
circulates in the human body
trees are designed to circulate two
kinds of SAP throughout their bodies
carrying all the substances a tree's
cells need to live
the first is phloem SAP containing the
sugars generated in leaves during
photosynthesis phloem SAP is thick like
honey and flows down the plants phloem
tissue to distribute sugar throughout
the tree by the end of its journey the
phloem SAP has thinned into a watery
substance pooling at the base of the
tree right beside the phloem is the
trees other tissue type the xylem this
tissue is packed with nutrients and ions
like calcium potassium and iron which
the tree has absorbed through its roots
here at the trees base there are more of
these particles in one tissue than the
other so the water from the phloem SAP
is absorbed into the xylem to correct
the balance this process called
osmotic movement creates nutrient-rich
xylem sap which will then travel up the
trunk to spread those nutrients through
the tree but this journey faces a
formidable obstacle gravity to
accomplish this Herculean task the xylem
relies on three forces transpiration
capillary action and
pressure as part of photosynthesis
leaves open and closed pores called
stomata these openings allow oxygen and
carbon dioxide in and out of the leaf
but they also create an opening through
which water evaporates this evaporation
called transpiration creates negative
pressure in the xylem pulling watery
xylem SAP up the tree this pull is aided
by a fundamental property of water
called capillary action in narrow tubes
the attraction between water molecules
and the adhesive forces between the
water and its environment can beat out
gravity this capillary motion is in full
effect in xylem filaments thinner than
human hair and where these two forces
pull the SAP the osmotic movement at the
trees base creates route pressure
pushing fresh asylum SAP up the trunk
together these forces launch SAP to
dizzying heights distributing nutrients
and growing new leaves to
photosynthesize far above the trees
roots but despite these sophisticated
systems every centimeter is a fight
against gravity as trees grow taller and
taller the supply of these vital fluids
begins to dwindle at a certain height
trees can no longer afford the lost
water that evaporates during
photosynthesis and without the
photosynthesis needed to support
additional growth the tree instead turns
its resources towards existing branches
this model known as the hydraulic
limitation hypothesis is currently our
best explanation for why trees have
limited Heights even in perfect growing
conditions and using this model
alongside growth rates and known needs
for nutrients and photosynthesis
researchers have been able to propose
height limits for specific species so
far these limits have held up even the
world's tallest tree still Falls about
15 metres below the cap
researchers are still investigating the
possible explanations for this plenum
and there may not be one universal
reason why trees stop growing
but until we learn more the height of
trees is yet another way that gravity
literally shapes life on earth so what's
going on all the way at the top of these
super tall trees find out in this video
about one scientists bold exploration of
the canopy of an ancient redwood
[Music]